are the current ideas about prevention
sufficient for a next pandemic yeah i
mean
so there's a lot that is known but that
is ignored or denied by the public
health
apparatus
um
that's one thing so you know
what what's included in current ideas
and then the other thing is what's the
nature of the pathogen and the next
pandemic so as we talked about briefly
in the first hour two hours whatever it
was
you know what we know
some things are likely to be
having sufficient vitamin d levels
is going to be healthy for you and good
at um
predicting a robust immune response for
you as an individual regardless of
pathogen but there are some pathogens
for which it will matter less
right
and
go on well i was just going to say the
upshot is that for a large number of
pathogens known and unknown were you to
engage in a proactive campaign to get
people aware of vitamin d how it is
normally produced what you do if you're
deficient how likely it is that you are
deficient yes were you to blanket the
world with that information so that
people could correct their own
deficiencies a great many pathogens that
might otherwise spread will find there
are nots below one and will not get a
foothold right so what kind of knowledge
is that it's knowledge about you know
you may never know that there was going
to be a pandemic if you did that thing
you might have something that would have
been a pandemic but for your proactive
thing and you'll never get credit for
having prevented it well this i mean
this is unfortunately one of the
problems with public health right that
uh
the best public health policies and
practitioners never know that what they
did worked
and the incentive structure doesn't and
so you know it's much more impressive
to come in to chaos and and appear to
solve a problem than to avert the
problem in the first place because if
you hurt the problem in the first place
others can legitimately say how do you
know you averted it you don't know you
averted it maybe it just wasn't going to
happen and that does and that does make
preventative measures hard to assess
right if they're actually done in
advance if they're actually prophylactic
but um but vitamin d is so widely
understood to have so many
uh
beneficial effects in the body
that that would
you know i think that we would see ah
well so it doesn't require any new
pathogens we would see the prediction
i'm happy to make and i'm not the first
one at all to make is that if the world
got a hold of its vitamin d levels that
we would have a reduction in cold and
flu in the winter in you know in
november through march in the northern
hemisphere and
the the southern winter as well in the
in the relevant months there yeah i've
heard uh ryan cole say and it may be a
slight exaggeration but i don't think so
there is no cold or flu season there's
vitamin d deficiency season right
right
so you know other ideas about prevention
part of part of the problem you know the
the party line solutions
have so many drawbacks have so many
negatives that no one is talking about
and you know that we talked about some
with regard to to masking in the first
in the first hour
but the the lack of touch
the lack of uh
of just even you know the lack of
serendipity and just you know like this
is so trivial but just like being able
to walk through it early
early in the pandemic that whole first
summer northern hemisphere summer
here in portland the farmers markets
which i used to love and just stopped
going to them
once they reopened you had to walk in a
particular place there were only a
certain number of people who walk into
this opener market right like walk in
certain and then there were arrows and
you could only go clockwise or
counterclockwise you could only go this
that and the other it's like that's not
the whole the whole idea here
is oh that looks interesting oh i wonder
if that guy's peaches are better than
hers oh oh i do want some some
strawberries today and oh you're going
to walk in lockstep
around this farmer's market well that's
not interesting in any way and um and
it's not it's not good for the human
psyche it's not good for the vendors at
these places and the social distancing
the partitions between people
like literal partitions and the fact
that we're you know mostly seeing each
other through screens
would some are would some of those
measures i think the farmers market
thing was just stupid entirely but were
some of those measures effective against
would some of those measures have been
effective against some kinds of
respiratory viruses
probably
but at what cost and when do we get to
start um addressing the other side of
the equation
because preventing the next pandemic
at the cost of
two years of madness and mayhem and
chaos in which the disparity in wealth
and
well-being in the world just got far
more extreme than it was before
that wasn't worth it
yeah but
a i think we are partially downstream
from a sales pitch about how likely
um
streets pandemics are and
you know this is like
the perfect storm of awful right you had
um
salesmen behind the scenes pitching the
idea that we absolutely had to find the
most dangerous pathogens we could and
turbocharge them as quickly as possible
so that we would be ready if they ever
left out of a cage of their the cave of
their own accord
which was
nonsense it sounds a cage number one
yeah number one thing to do to prevent
the next pandemic is get a hold of these
nitwits and keep them away from power
and money yes and you know notice
that it's not like this was a secret we
had a battle in 2015 over whether or not
the gain of function uh research program
was itself the hazard to planet earth
legislatively we did the right thing and
then
again that snake wall salesman
overrode the gain of function ban and
offshored the work so you need to get a
hold of your political corruption
problem if you want to prevent the next
pandemic because the most likely place
for your next pandemic to come from is
the nitwix nitwits with their sales
pitch about turbocharging viruses
but
the other thing which i proposed at the
beginning of all of this
was that we ought to be
studying
and i'm people will say we already are i
don't believe them we need to be
studying the way normal pathogens
actually work right we need to have a an
institute that is freed from corruption
that studies how normal things like
colds and flu and other uh viruses
actually transmit and behave and evolve
and we do this haphazardly but if we did
it so that you know we started tracking
variants of the common cold as they
actually spread across the globe and
figured out what measures actually
did function at minimal disruption right
and then the other the third part of
this is
at the beginning of the pandemic we
started to have the first
decent conversations in public about
uh how things are transmitted yep right
the fact that people began to understand
fomite transmission they began to
understand that they might be wiping
things into their eyes that would then
make them sick right that conversation
was healthy
the fact that it took covid to have us
having conversation about getting
conscious about whether or not you're
touching your face yeah right all of
these things are important and so the
point is a we need people who are not in
the business of lying
to study the question of how things are
transmitted even normal mundane everyday
things that are not important to control
like colds
right in order that they can take that
knowledge and
map it onto things that are important to
control so we need to prevent ourselves
from releasing these things we need to
understand how the transmission
uh
works so that we can uh learn from the
mundane stuff for the stuff that
actually does need to be controlled and
then we need to educate the public right
you
it's as important in school that you
study the question of how these things
are transmitted you know as it is that
you
study i don't know the
capitals of the various states or
whatever other nonsense kids time on
right just yeah
this is a kind of knowledge that will
actually save weeks of your life from
being compromised by pathogens if you
just simply understand where you're in
danger of contacting them and how you
can alter your behavior to reduce the
chances that you do
right if you could reduce the number of
colds and flus that you had in a
lifetime by
20
how much education would that be worth
you know
it's a lot and uh you would be teaching
students how to think through systems
and come to conclusions that aren't uh
that aren't just about memorization
unlike you know your example of the
state capitals
is both a stereotype and still true i
think and a very good one it's very easy
to
teach that sort of thing because you're
either right or you're wrong
if we're going to go into memorization
territory let's at least make it math
right like let you know at least at
least with like there are some things
and you have just basic basic basic
arithmetic things like your times tables
um that you should know and it is a
memory thing like yeah you can derive it
each time but that's going to take a
while so why not just memorize it and um
yeah there's a lot of things that most
people who actually have a lot to say
about a lot of things do have that they
can pull from memory
but uh memory is not the thing memory is
not the main thing and what you want to
you know have is you know an
architecture in your head of like what's
connected to what so you can say oh well
i don't i can't pull that fact up but i
can connect it to this to this to this
to this and there it is right
and you know the state capitals
have the virtue which is to say not a
virtue at all
of being you know very easy to assess
for a teacher like you either you either
got got it or you didn't it's sacramento
or it's not right um but there's no
devising it that you could possibly do
you cannot derive by first principles
what the capital of any state is you
might have a memory associated with a
thing you might have a mnemonic but a
mnemonic is another cheat and it's
taking up more brain space and
you know
it is useful that i still know most not
all by any means of the state capitals
kind of
i think it would be more useful that i
knew
for sure and i like i'm my dad did a lot
of maps with me i know a lot of
geography most more than most americans
but
um it would have been much more
important to learn uh
50 the locations and
borders of 50 countries
that most americans don't know or even
the most americans do know than the
capitals of the 50 states sure start
with the 50 states themselves but then
go to the capitals no do something more
interesting more important more global
and we're still all in like you can't
derive from first principles territory
and i'd rather see more math if you're
going to do memorization and then i'd
really rather see more okay
if you start with a and b
what do you need like what would you
have to know in order to also know
whether c was true something like that
yep i do think you can derive washington
state's capital from first principles
but it might be the only one
washington state's capital
really i think so you wouldn't know the
name but
it kind of has to be right at the bottom
of the puget sound right because that's
where the stuff the logs
get to the water in the first place that
it's deep enough to take them to the
pacific
so you would you would
i mean in the first place depending on
where you're starting but seattle would
have been just as fine a a choice and
seattle was point is for anything south
anything coming up
that's that's a lot of epicycles
no i wouldn't use them to cycles i would
use trucks yeah then um trucks when when
the state of washington was being well
all right trains i see
[Music]
you